good afternoon i'm lieutenant ray
spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this afternoon to give you
a briefing on a homicide that we are
investigating near the intersection of
cheyenne
and jones the details that i have this
afternoon are very preliminary but at
around 1
30 this afternoon we received report of
a black male in his early 30s
behind this abandoned business suffering
from a gunshot wound
officers and medical personnel arrived
and that male was transported to umc
trauma where he was pronounced deceased
what we have learned at this point
is that people who work in the area
heard a gunshot at that point they
observed that male victim
lying on the ground immediately after
the gunshot
we have no witnesses to the incident we
are urging anybody who has any
information to please reach out to crime
stoppers
you can do that anonymously and there's
reward money available if your
information leads to the arrest and
conviction
you can also reach out to homicide at
lvmpd.com so with that i'll take a
couple questions but again very limited
information right now
on what occurred
so there appear to be surveillance
cameras but because the business is
vacant we don't believe they work we
have not gone
in to take a ch to look yet but we're
also canvassing the area
for other businesses in an effort to
obtain video from any other businesses
yes he is a black male in his early 30s
again i do know i'm just not putting
that information out so
that information was provided in the
original phone call to 9-1-1 but again
we're still trying to
locate any actual witnesses who uh
witnessed the incident
it does not appear to be anything like
that we just know that he was found by
himself
right behind the business after the
person called in the 911
no again we have no witnesses who
actually witnessed
anything the only thing that was heard
was the
call that prompted the 9-1-1 call and
outside of that i'm urging anybody who
has any information that could lead
to suspects to please reach out to crime
stoppers and again that's 100 percent
anonymous
and you can get reward money for
providing that information
all right thank you guys